we have breaking news from Washington
congressman Tom Marino president Trump's
nominee to be federal drug czar has now
withdraw on his nomination an
investigation by 60 minutes and the
Washington Post highlighted Marino's
role in the weakening of the Drug
Enforcement Administration's control
over opioid drug distributors the
president said yesterday he would look
again at this issue I did see the report
we're gonna look into the report we're
gonna take it very seriously
because we're gonna have a major
announcement probably next week on the
drug crisis and on the opioid massive
problem representative Marino's
sponsored a law limiting the DEA s
enforcement power that took effect in
2016 more than 64,000 Americans died
that year from drug overdoses most from
opioids Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
Nancy good morning good morning here's
what the president tweeted a short time
ago representative Tom Marino has
informed me that he is withdrawing his
name from consideration as drug czar tom
is a fine man and a great congressman
but an increasing number of Democrats
had been pushing this president to
choose someone else to represent the
nation's fight against drugs Tom Marino
going to be the drug czar he's going to
do a great job as recently as last week
president Trump was touting his pick to
lead the nation's drug control effort
but in the wake of the 60 Minutes
Washington Post investigation he
acknowledged he was having second
thoughts we're gonna look into the
report we're gonna take it very
seriously on Monday West Virginia
Democrat Joe Manchin sent a letter to
President Trump urging him to pull
Marino's nomination there's nobody in my
state going to believe that he is going
to be sincere or be effective it's
disturbing lawmakers are struggling to
figure out how they unwittingly passed a
bill weakening the DEA those in favor
say aye
the one-and-a-half-year-old law makes it
harder for drug enforcement officers to
block suspicious shipments of opiates
that can flood the black market and fuel
addiction there should have been a giant
flashing red light Missouri Democrat
Claire McCaskill introduced a bill
Monday to repeal the law it was fairly
clear some of them were trying to work
with the drug companies but Utah
Republican
Orrin Hatch defended the law and his
role in writing it anyone who claims
that I or anyone else steamrolled DEA
and DOJ in this bill is either ignorant
or woefully misinformed and other
sponsors said they got mixed messages
from law enforcement California Democrat
Judy Chu said when she met with the
acting head of the DEA he insisted that
the bill would not negatively impact
their work one republican author of the
bill tennessee congresswoman Marsha
Blackburn says if it has had unintended
consequences they should make changes
right away so there is now mounting
bipartisan agreement that something is
going to have to happen in the wake of
this 60 minutes Washington Post
investigation Nancy thank you very much